Behati Prinsloo bears her baby bump by  the pool the mom-to-be showed off her  growing belly via Instagram on Saturday  in a white two-piece joking in the  caption quotes bellybuttons still on  point Adam Levine and his wife stepped  out to grab a bite at Nobu restaurant in  Malibu California  the supermodel flaunted her figure in a  casual LBD Asma hotties do de quickly  approaches in September the supermodel  has been adjusting to her figure and  documenting her progress on social media  Pahadi hilariously shared this photo  last week peering over her stomach  writing can't see my toes but the  expectant mom continues to prove why she  is pregnancy goals he or she is posing  topless for a photoshoot with her belly  on full display  Adam and Behati are expecting their  first child together  a baby girl I'm ready to be a dud you  ready yeah  you